let me ask this question about uh mental
health okay so
basketball in the 90s that's when i
followed basketball closely yeah okay
i don't remember anything with mental
health maybe there was i don't remember
and i remember one story in the 90s not
to get you off sharif
well no he had other issues but remember
willie burton i do i know willie
personally yeah well he's minnesota
right that's right i remember he stopped
playing because of depression
okay remember this story people laugh
like dude what are you doing well willie
and i love him to death and and if he's
watching this and i'm speaking out of
turn i i apologize but willie willie has
some struggles with addiction
as many players did so and and when you
say
you don't remember hearing stories about
mental health that's the double cross
from triple cross i was talking about
with the media yes is that so they
presented it like when i said mental
health nobody knew what i was talking so
here's where i'm going with this so when
you say panic attack i know exactly what
panic attacks are because i went through
it for a year and a half when you start
a business and you put your life savings
into it
and you're about to lose it all it's
very very
challenging because you busted your tail
for a decade to save a half a million
dollars in your 20s and you put in the
business and you're down to 13 000
and everybody's looking at you to pay
their salaries and commissions and
you're about to bust and you have to you
just got married you told everybody
you're going to do this and it's not
going to work out so it's a very the
pressure on you you feel like you're
having a heart attack by the way like an
elephant is sitting on your head i've
been very open about that story i've
gone through i've gone through panic
attacks and i'd go to emergency i'm like
what the hell is going on my body's like
sir you're just having a very bad panic
attack right and then they would give me
iv for a couple hours and say yeah your
body's exhausted right you need to sleep
are you getting it this has happened
probably
five times in my career okay where i
have to go to the hospital and get ibs
at times that's no that's no small feat
i mean are we talking i think five is
actually not bad if it happens every
three years it's actually anyways i'm
not going there so let's go over here so
athletes today so here's here's where i
see it so i think there's a difference
between
so you so you know you saw ronda rousey
after the fight oh i was suicidal
michael phelps you know he was he went
through it
serena williams even talked about how it
was for her you know uh uh allie raisman
talked about it we have even the recent
one the tennis player
yeah so simone biles so how mental
health so some some kevin love is even
in that community right kevin love
talking about you guys had a little uh
he was the one to come after me so so
then here becomes here becomes the the
difference how
how
you know there's a part of it where like
when i was going through it i wasn't
public about it i was to myself right
now i was privately talking about it
with my
doctors and whoever i was dealing with
but it wasn't public because your
business you're not really talking about
i talked about it years later when i
went through it but
you know like when you're hearing with
naomi going through it you're hearing
kevin throw go through it what is the
difference between man you just went
through a set of losses and it's tough
and you got to go through it versus
you're actually going through
mental health how do you differentiate
between those two
well i think
was two things
first
i think mental health has been
weaponized
by the
been weaponized through wokism number
one
and i think a huge part of the medical
community in the mental health community
the psychological the field of
psychology through the universities
has also been
corrupted
by woke-ism by liberalism
and that reflects in even the
diagnostical
ways to
determine the severity of mental illness
um
but
i think that's when you get down into
the details
i think in general the premise that i
was coming from is we're not even
acknowledging that mental health or the
human psychology is a central part of
human beingness to be and and so let's
start there and now if we need to
reorient the details
we can do that and and to your point i
think that you know all of those cases
are very different simone's case is
different than osakas and and serena's
kevin they're all different
um and they all carry their own unique
unique signature from a mental health
standpoint but i think very clearly if
people are saying they have an issue
they probably are the question is what
issue are they actually having and what
relation does that have to what they're
doing what they're saying they can do or
can't do in my case i really wasn't
saying that there's anything i couldn't
do based on my mental health which is a
significant difference from
osaka osaka was saying i'm having
depression i really don't want the
pressure i'm going to step away because
i can't perform or take
the the scrutiny or magnifying glass
with what i'm going through
mine was a complete 180 degrees from
that i was saying look i have anxiety
but i can play i can do everything you
ask me to do i just want us to have an
understanding about this this
topic
open dialogue and i'd like it to be in
writing because everything else in our
industry is in writing
so it was more of a business
uh how much money did that cost you
a couple hundred million a couple
hundred million dollars yeah yeah not a
lot of money just a couple hundred
million i mean if you would have yeah
you would have stayed in the league for
a decade and got a second contract and a
max contract 500 million yeah i mean i
mean uh likability commercial you know
all of it endorsements so say low 2000
for the people that don't understand
royce's story and we'll get into a lot
of it yeah you were billed as sort of a
next lebron type of like if you're going
to lead you're you're a power forward
who also played point guard right
lebron-esque right six eight strong
court vision rebound pass score
dominate in the fourth quarter like when
you're saying these numbers a couple
hundred million a half a billion
if you would have lived up your
potential you're actually not being
uh facetious with these numbers
so so for you know you know what it is
for me let me explain to you what it is
for me so i have i have an internal
uh uh what do you call it there's a
good pad
all these guys are saying yeah so one is
sitting here saying stop bitching and
making excuses and kind of make it work
yeah and the other one's saying to do it
understand him he's going through
challenges right and i i tend to lean
towards the guy that says stop bitching
that's the guy i listen to the most
i tend to listen i don't know if i'm
making any sense or not i tend to lean
towards the guy that's like dude listen
you think you're going through hard
times how about the guys that are in war
right now that are not missing their
birthday of their newborn baby or you
know they just lost their best friend
lost the limb and you're sitting here
worried about you're about to lose a
half a million dollars your life savings
grow up you know you're living in
america you're the luckiest man alive so
that's where i lean towards 90 of the
time okay so now here's what happened
when i was going through this process
i'm curious so i go through different
doctors
and 99 of doctors recommended what uh
drawing occasionally hey take this hey
i'm like no i want a long-term solution
like even right now my back my lower
back on the right side challenges when i
go to chiropractor and i always ask the
chiropractor give me a like what is it i
can do one time and it's gone right and
they'll say listen sorry man that's just
not gonna happen you're six fours you
know six four and a half you got
military knees your lower back you were
in the army for a few years you carried
that weight this is something you're
gonna have to handle for the rest of
your life okay so eventually i went to
one guy and he recommended me a book it
was like a 60 page book and i read this
book
and he explained depression
and anxiety in the simplest way possible
to control your imagination and here's
all it was and and it's simplified
because at any point i was feeling i
went to that state he said anytime
you're depressed you're spending a lot
of time living in the past
any time your anxiety and panic is high
you're spending way too much time living
in the future he said try to live as
much in the current
as possible on what you can do that is
the best state to be so if you catch
yourself your brain or your mind is
taking you a little oh my god i should
have done this i regret donut dude
you're going to get depressed come back
to the present and something what if
something happens what if there's this
what if there's a totally get it you
know you're you're a visionary you're
living in the future that's good go
there every once in a while to get
excited or kind of prepare and
anticipate but try to come as much to
the present as possible so for me
sometimes when i see this
and a player or an athlete or a pal or
somebody that's running and they say oh
that that was a lot of pressure on me
and i was going through as i was going
through that
yeah that's what it's supposed to do
that's right it's supposed to create
pressure so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]